après la nuit de la comète diffusé hier
soir sur fr3 depuis la cité des sciences
et des techniques de la ville est une
forêt au cours de laquelle la sonde
liautaud nous a fait parvenir des images
exceptionnelles de la comète de halley
le public a pris possession aujourd'hui
de ce nouveau vaisseau unique en son
genre cette cité des sciences où l'on
espère chaque année plusieurs millions
de visiteurs marie-hélène bono 14h cet
après midi les portes s'ouvrent sur la
cité des sciences pour 20 francs prix
spécial d'ouverture ils vont découvrir
explorer et l'exposition temporaire sur
l'or dès le mois de juin des
distributeurs automatiques de tickets
comme dans le métro seront installés ce
qui facilitera l'entrée et pour les
premiers jours les philatélistes avaient
pris d'assaut le bureau de poste pour
l'émission du timbre du premier jour
d'ouverture avec oblitération à la date
d'aujourd'hui à 15h 2200 visiteurs
avaient pris possession de la cité des
sciences
actuellement la capacité d'accueil est
de 3500 personnes
au delà il faudra attendre à l'extérieur
pour réguler la foule avec impatience
l'ouverture rue à pression
les bars quoi exactement tout qu'est-ce
qui va voir comment savez vous demandez
je suis à l'autre bout je suis à gela 30
mai à vannes est de vous là l'un des
lieux les plus insolites et les plus
visités de cette cité le monde sonore un
peu plus joli
c'est marrant tous là depuis environ un
quart d'heure et je trouve ça assez 13
pays colo
vers quoi vous jouez là à chanter ça
vous amuse beaucoup mais apparemment ça
donne c'est multiplient peur c'est
gratuit pour chaque unité il faut
environ huit heures pour tout découvrir
c'est dire s'ils reviendront